LEVEL.
I GET THIS COUNTRY BACK ON
TRACK.
YOU CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN
STARTING IN SIX DAYS.
HERE NOW WITH MORE, HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER, HOPES TO BE
SPEAKER ONE DAY, KEVIN
McCARTHY.
HOW ARE YOU SIR?
>> I'M GOOD.
>> Hannity: ARE LOOKING AT THE
STATE OF INFLATION, A 41 YEAR
HIGH THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
TRANSITORY, RECORD HIGH GAS
PRICES, WE'VE DEPLETED THE
STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVES,
WIDE OPEN BORDERS, THEY WERE
SECURE UNDER DONALD TRUMP.
I'M LOOKING AT NO BAIL LAWS LIKE
WERE TALKING ABOUT, DEFUND THE
POLICE LIKE WERE TALKING ABOUT
GREAT I'M LOOKING AT WOKE
SCHOOLS VERSUS CLASSICAL
EDUCATION.
AND I'M THINKING THIS IS THE
BIGGEST TRI- SELECTION AMERICA
HAS HAD IN MY LIFETIME THAT I
CAN THINK OF.
THE LEFT HAS NEVER BEEN THIS
RADICAL.
SO WHY ARE SOME OF THESE RACES
AS CLOSE AS THEY ARE?
>> YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE PULSE BUT HE ALSO WILL HAVE
TO TALK ABOUT WITH THE PRESENCE
OF THE NIGHT.
HE WASN'T UNITING US.
THE DEMOCRATS WERE DIVIDING US
AS THEY MOVE FORWARD.
THEY JUST WANT TO DISTRACT FROM
THE DISASTERS THEY CREATED.
ALL THOSE TOPICS YOU BROUGHT UP?
I LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT'S
SPEECH.
I DON'T REMEMBER HEARING
ANYTHING ABOUT INFLATION, GAS,
BORDER, FENTANYL, CRIME.
OR THE 98 INDIVIDUALS ON THE
BORDER ON THE TERRORIST WATCH
LIST.
THIS IS A HINGE ELECTION IN THE
NEXT SIX DAYS, DEFINING ELECTION
LIKE A 1980 ELECTION.
WHICH DIRECTION DOES AMERICA
WANT TO GO?
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE THE
COMMITMENT TO AMERICA.
WE LITERALLY SPELL OUT WHAT
WE'LL DO, MAKE US ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
AN ECONOMY THAT STRONG.
A SECURE BORDER.
FUNDING OF THE POLICE.
STOPPING THE PROSECUTORS WHO ARE
WOKE.
A PARENT'S BILL OF RIGHTS.
AND SAVE AND STRENGTHEN MEDICARE
AND SOCIAL SECURITY.
HAVE A GOVERNMENT THAT IS
ACCOUNTABLE, A FUTURE THAT'S
BUILT ON FREEDOM.
I THINK THE ENTIRE NATION SHOULD
LOOK AT WHAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
DONE WITH ONE PARTY RULE, LOOK
AT WHAT THE COMMITMENT SAYS, AND
MAKE A DECISION.
I'M TALKING TO ALL AMERICANS,
NOT JUST REPUBLICANS BUT
INDEPENDENTS, DEMOCRATS, THE
GREEN PARTY.
YOU KNOW THIS NATION CAN BE
BETTER.
YOU WANT TO PICK SOMEBODY WHO
HAS A PLAN TO TURN THIS NATION
AROUND AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WERE GOING TO DO.
>> Hannity: KEVIN, YOUR
COMMITMENTS TO AMERICA, I'VE
READ THEM, I AGREE WITH THEM,
IT'S AMERICA FIRST ON THE MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGENDA, IN OTHER
WORDS, RETURN TO POLICIES THAT
WERE WORKING 21 MONTHS AGO.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT EVERY COMIC
ASSESSMENT HAS SIGNED ON TO IT.
ANOTHER QUESTION IS, WILL YOU
FOLLOW THROUGH ON IT?
NOT ONLY WHEN JOE BIDEN'S
PRESIDENT WHEN HOPEFULLY A
REPUBLICAN IS ELECTED AS WELL
AND IT CAN BE ENACTED INTO LAW.
THERE WERE SYMBOLIC VOTES ON
REPEALING AND REPLACING
OBAMACARE AND IT NEVER BECAME A
REALITY WHEN IT MATTERED IN
2017, DID IT?
>> IN THE SENATE IT WAS STOPPED.
OUR COMMITMENT TO AMERICA
PREMISES WHAT TO DO TO GET OUT
OF THE HOUSE.
ON THE VERY FIRST DAY ON JANUAR.
WILL REPEAL THE IRS AGENTS.
I BELIEVE THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD
BE THERE TO HELP YOU NOT GO
AFTER YOU.
HOLD YOUR FEET TO THE FIRE.
REMEMBER AFTER THE 94
REVOLUTION, IT TOOK THREE TIMES
PUTTING ON THE PRESIDENT'S DESK
BEFORE THEY HAD WELFARE REFORM.
WE'LL FIGHT AND MOVE THIS
FORWARD.
WE NEED YOU NOT ONLY TO JOIN
WITH US BOTH STAY WITH US AS WE
MOVE TO THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE
AND THE PRESENCE DESK.
YOUR TOWN HALLS, SEAN, HAVE BEEN
TREMENDOUS, TALKING ABOUT
SOLUTIONS.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO HAVE THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
BECAUSE IT GIVES US AN ABILITY
TO REPEAL THESE REGULATIONS WITH
THE COMING CONGRESSIONAL REVIEW
ACT WHICH IS 51 VOTES IN THE
SENATE.
WE CAN DO RECONCILIATION WITH 51
VOTES IN SENATE AND PUT A BILL
ON THE PRESIDENT'S DESK.
WE HAVE THE APPROPRIATIONS
PROCESS.
SO THEY ARE A NUMBER OF WAYS WE
CAN ACHIEVE WHAT WE TALK ABOUT
IN THE COMMITMENT, EVEN THOUGH
THE PRESIDENT IS SITTING AS AN
OFFICE RIGHT NOW.
>> Hannity: LET ME ASK YOU
THIS THEN, BECAUSE THE ONE BIG
POWER CONGRESS WILL HAVE, IF YOU
HAVE THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE
ESPECIALLY, THAT'S THE PART OF
THE PURSE.
THE ABILITY TO FUND GOVERNMENT
ARE NOT.
I'D BET EVERYTHING I HAD THAT
THERE IS GONNA COME A POINT
WHERE DEMOCRATS ARE IN AND SAY,
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
SHUTDOWN THE GOVERNMENT!
IN THERE AND A TAKE AWAY YOUR
SOCIAL SECURITY!
WILL REPUBLICANS, BY THE WAY
SOCIAL SECURITY WILL BE FUNDED,
WHEN THEY SHUTDOWN CONGRESS BY
THE WAY IT'S A FREE VACATION
USUALLY IN THE END FOR PEOPLE.
MY QUESTION IS, WILL YOU USE THE
PUBLIC, POWER, WILL REPUBLICANS
STAND STRONG WHEN IT COMES TO
THE MOMENTS TO STAND UP AND
USING THE POWER YOU DO HAVE.
>> BRITTANY IS A POWER BUT I
WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR.
WE WILL ALWAYS SAVE AND
STRENGTHEN SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE.
THAT DOES NOT CHANGE IN THE
OUTCOME.
YOU SHOULD HAVE A DEBATE ABOUT
HOW WE SPEND GOVERNMENT MONEY.
THEY SHOULD BE A BLANK CHECK FOR
ANYTHING.
IT'S THE TAXPAYERS HARD-EARNED
MONEY BEING SPENT.
WE SHOULD ELIMINATE THIS
WASTEFUL WASHINGTON SPENDING.
AND WE CAN DO THAT.
THIS IS THE PART THAT WE NEED
THE PEOPLE.
AND ON THE VERY FIRST DAY, WE
HAVE ALREADY SENT THE
PRESERVATION LETTERS.
GRID AND HOLD GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT HASN'T
BEEN DONE.
YOU SHOULD KNOW WORK COVID
ORIGINATED FROM, WHY THE DOJ
WENT AFTER PARENTS FOR GOING TO
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS, WHAT
HAPPENED THOSE LAST 60 DAYS OF
AFGHANISTAN SO NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN, SO WE DON'T HAVE 13 NEW
GOLD STAR FAMILIES AGAIN.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
ITEMS THAT WILL BE LOOKING AT.
BUT WHAT WILL BE DOING IS MOVING
POLICY THAT MAKES US ENJOY
ENERGY INDEPENDENT, AND ATCHISON
AMERICA BUT WE SHOULD MAKE THE
REST OF THE WORLD DEPENDENT ON
US.
IT MAKES THE WORLD MORE SECURE
AND MAKES AMERICA STRONGER.
>> Hannity: IT WOULD MAKE
AMER